yes
so they will deliver remarks and then we
will take uh questions starting with
questions in the room and then on zoom
floor is yours
okay
hello everyone
this morning
by russia
we were also joined by ukraine's
minister of finance
siddhi
whose country is so bravely resisting
the brutality of a tyrant
minister marcinko joined us from a
windowless room
we could see a spartan caught behind him
and a blue and yellow flag
taped to the wall
he looked tired
but he was determined
he thanked us for our support
assured us that ukraine would win
and asked us to continue ratcheting up
the pressure on russia
ministers
coordinated and devastating sanctions
that we have imposed on the russian
economy
these include measures directly
targeting the russian central bank
which is a president vladimir putin's
war chest
the
with the president
[Music]
and
yeah
and on this point
we are resolute
because as the g7
canada germany
france
italy
japan the united kingdom and the united
states
we understand the stakes of this great
conflict between democracy
and dictatorship
the battleground today
is ukraine
but this is our fight too
president putin has made a grave and
historic error
this is not the behavior of a superpower
this is the last gasp of a failing
kleptocracy
and president putin has now become an
international pariah
the free world is united in our
conviction that his brutal assault on
democracy
on the rules-based international order
and on the people of ukraine
cannot be allowed to succeed
and we are united in our support for
brave ukraine
and now i turn over the floor to my
colleague our minister of international
development minister sajin harj please
thank you deputy prime minister
today we continue to show that the world
stands shoulder to shoulder with our
ukrainian friends
in the face of vladimir putin's naked
territorial aggression
there can be no doubt that vladimir
putin's unjustifiable invasion of
ukraine will live in infamy amongst the
dictators and autocrats from the 21st
first correction from the 20th century
the decisions we make today and over the
coming weeks and months
will not only determine how we are
remembered by history
but they will fundamentally shape the
world for our children
and our grandchildren
i had the privilege to attend president
zelinski's inauguration
and i think of the words from his speech
he said
i really do not want my pictures in your
offices
for the president is not an icon an idol
or a portrait
hang your kids photos instead and look
at them each time you are making a
decision
now in the last week i can't stop
thinking about the impact
of this unjustifiable aggression that
has had on his children
and the children of ukraine whose lives
have been thrown into chaos
classrooms have been replaced by bomb
shelters
playgrounds have become battlefields
beds have become the hard ground
it is why
as canadians we have and will continue
to step up to show that we will stand on
the right side of history
it is wide today announced that the
united nations humanitarian humanitarian
flash appeal and the regional refugee
response plan for ukraine that canada
will be supporting this appeal by
providing 100 million dollars canadian
for humanitarian assistance for the
people of ukraine and those who have
been forced to flee to neighboring
countries
this funding will support life-saving
services such as shelter water
sanitation as well as food assistance we
will continue to be there with our
ukrainian friends and partners during
this difficult time slava ukraine merci
beaucoup thank you
now i'll pass it over to minister not
thank you so much arch
good afternoon
like many canadians i woke up this
morning to more disturbing images of
what is happening in ukraine right now
in particular the bombardment of
residential areas killing families and
children in kharkiv and a massive column
of russian tanks
approaching kiev
to know that civilians children and
families lives are being taken is even
more horrific
it is important for canadians and indeed
the world to pay close attention to what
is unfolding right now
at the same time
i want canadians to know that we are
leaving no stone unturned
to help our friends in ukraine
by way of
support including military support
through military support support that we
are providing
i think about it in three trashes
trash one
in the last few weeks we announced
approximately 10 million dollars worth
of lethal and non-lethal aid
ranging from sniper rifles carbines
pistols body armor and 1.5 million
rounds of ammunition all of which
arrived on or before february 22nd
trash
million million
specifically protective goggles helmets
bulletproof vests and gas masks
on february 28 yesterday we confirmed
that we will send even more lethal aid
to our friends in ukraine in the form of
100 carl gustav anti-armor weapon
systems
as well as related accessories and
scopes and 2 000 rounds of 84 millimeter
ammunition to go with them
transit
on february 27th we also approved
additional airlift support in the form
of cc-130s and up to 50 calf canadian
armed forces personnel who will offer
the transportation of goods and
personnel in support of the government
of canada and nato efforts writ large in
europe
the first such flight left for europe
yesterday and the second is leaving
today
all of this to say
is that we have and we will continue to
support ukraine
and to this end today
i am confirming that in addition to the
three tranches of bilateral support that
i outlined above
the remainder of which we are working to
deliver as quickly as possible
canada will also be providing
1600 fragmentation vests and just under
four hundred thousand individual meal
packs to our friends in ukraine these
are items that have been requested and
that we are providing
i found a suit
[Music]
we are
the rest of the assistants as quickly as
possible
canada will also provide
1600 and almost 400 individuals
it is absolutely shocking to see putin
use the military equipment that russia
has at its disposal
to kill innocent people
and it is important to recognize that
all of the countries that stand with
ukraine
and that are participating in this
effort canada included
have much to bring to the table
in terms
of supplies
and support
and fortitude we will keep working hard
for the people of ukraine and for the
sovereignty of ukraine in coordination
with
use the raised hand function if you uh
would like to ask a question come on
how close is canada to declaring war on
russia
[Music]
leaders the leaders of the g7 countries
which are the world's largest
democratic economies
had a conversation yesterday and
discussed the need
to continue maintaining pressure on
russia
i want to say
point out
measures on the russian economy
on the ruble
and
those sanctions were necessary
this morning
the g7 finance ministers and then
[Music]
to maintain pressure on russia this
discussion was with g7 finance ministers
russia is continuing the war so pressure
needs to be maintained as my colleague
the minister of defense explained
we are also
and we are also providing financial
assistance to the ukrainian government
i believe that canada
and our allies have all been very clear
at this point
uh day russia has
made the decision
set itself apart from the civilized
world
and for that reason
in
a war whose outcome will have practical
and significant consequences
for canada
ukraine
in starting a war
on ukraine a sovereign country
the russia
has violated the rules-based
international order
that
that is why this issue is so important
to our government
and to all the democracies of the world
miss freeland you have met uh president
and your view is he still rational
you're right
i have met plutier
president putin a number of times
[Music]
me
[Music]
20 meetings i did meet russia's economic
leaders they were there
and i was very clear
on the situation in ukraine
i addressed russia's economic
leaders
directly during the meeting
and i said that
the response of the democratic world
case of war against ukraine would be
dramatic and severe
so we did warn russia's leadership
we'll continue keeping up the pressure
we're seeing an increasing number of
canadians
wanting to travel to ukraine to provide
humanitarian and even military aid your
government and saying that
this would be a personal choice
is it a responsible thing to say to
canadians who might wish to travel to an
area where there is an armed conflict in
progress
i'll begin perhaps minister
would like to complete the answer
[Music]
freedom in this country and that is one
of our most important values in canada
we respect people's personal choices
the government's responsibility
that people who make dangerous choices
know that those are dangerous choices
that is why yesterday the prime minister
explained
that
a situation in ukraine is
dangerous i can
underscore that today but at the end of
the day
i have profound respect
for the right of every
man and woman in canada to make a choice
anita is there anything you would like
to add
completely
i completely agree
my colleagues
but i would like to say responsibility
yes it is our responsibility as a
government and in fact every
government's responsibility to set out
exactly what the risks are
to um explain what is happening in
ukraine
avoir
but yes the situation in ukraine is very
dangerous
situation we would like canada canadians
and we want them
be able to stay
do you have a plan if canadians find
themselves in difficulty in ukraine
are you going to end up with a situation
where you'll have to repatriate
canadians when things are complicated
enough on the ground
the uk and australia do not make
decisions for canada
[Music]
we were very clear
before the war that
things in ukraine are extremely
dangerous we have warned all canadian
citizens
of the danger
and
after the war started we said it would
no longer be possible
for
the government to protect
people in ukraine and that for example
includes members of my family
that is
how things stand
it is very serious but we have been
clear and we will continue to be clear
hi mr freelance great with ctv i'd say
there's no one in your government who
knows russian oligarchs as well as you
do and your government has sanctioned a
number of them but there's one key
person you haven't sanctioned which is
roman abramovich he's at the top of lexi
navalny's list of oligarchs to be
sanctioned he's one of the most
prominent oligarchs in the world and he
has substantial holdings in canada so
why hasn't your government sanctioned
him
um
we are looking carefully
at
the holdings of all russian oligarchs
and russian companies
inside canada
we're reviewing them
and
everything is on the table
yesterday a pentagon spokesperson said a
no-fly zone over ukraine is not
something the u.s is interested in today
boris johnson echoed that is it the
position of the canadian government that
we are not interested in enforcing a
no-fly zone over ukraine
our position there is aligned with that
of our allies and i don't know if our
minister of defense would like to
comment further
uh sure just picking up on where
christian left off
nato is a defensive alliance
and putting in place a no-fly zone would
be a severe escalation on the part of
nato and it is not
on the table at the current time we will
continue to support ukraine and nato in
many other ways including in terms of
the three tranches of aid i outlined in
my remarks and we've been doing that we
will continue to do that and we will
also continue to support nato's
defensive and deterrent posture
especially by increasing our support on
nato's eastern flank
thank you
yeah um mr finland ryan hamilton
national post
you've brought in economic sanctions
that were far in excess of what people
thought was possible even ten days ago
military support is coming from all of
our allies are you worried at all that
you're running out of levers to pull
here
that are reasonable and that the russian
government does not appear to be slowing
down
no
uh and i can elaborate a little bit um
we had a
very good
very substantive conversation with the
g7 finance ministers this morning
the ukrainian finance minister shared
with us some very creative and
thoughtful ideas that he has
and after he left us
we talked about
additional steps we can take
the reality is
that
russia's barbaric invasion of ukraine
has changed the world
the fact that vladimir putin has taken
this
profoundly damaging step
has put him beyond the pale
and
the world's democracies understand the
significance of what he has done
and
we really understand
that failure is not an option
and so i think everyone here has seen
everyone in canada has seen everyone in
the world has seen
that
once
the extent of vladimir putin's actions
became clear
we needed to
turn to
truly unconventional measures to take
steps that have never been taken before
um
you asked
ryan uh you know if i am worried that we
will run out of things to do and let me
point out
two additional
elements
that are in play here
that i think are really important and
are on the side of the good
uh the first one is the people of
ukraine
i think uh the world and i think the
kremlin
has been astonished at the strength and
the effectiveness of the opposition
and ukraine has been effective on every
front it has been effective on the cyber
front
it has been effective on the
communications front
it has been much more effective
militarily than anyone predicted before
this war started
and i think people have been astonished
although perhaps not ukrainians
themselves at the extent to which there
has been a true mobilization
really of every single ukrainian so
that's a really really important factor
uh and the second thing that's important
here is
russia is not the soviet union
um
russia is an economy in a society which
is deeply integrated into the west and
deeply integrated into the global
economy
and what we are seeing here from
vladimir putin is an attempt to have his
cake and eat it too
he wants to behave
like a communist dictator
but he and his entourage had thought
they could do that and continue to enjoy
all of the fruits of
global capitalism
and what the world decided really really
clearly
last week and then particularly this
weekend is
you don't get to do that
if you make war on the rules-based
international order
we're going to cut you out of the global
economy
i don't think that that is the deal
that putin's entourage signed up for and
i don't think that's the deal that the
russian people signed up for
so i do think our measures are important
they come second to the heroism of the
ukrainian people but i am proud that
canada is one of the countries that is
providing this important support
you talked a little bit about
vladimir putin being isolated having a
small entourage
are you worried that he is not seeing a
bigger picture here and that there may
be a need for is there a need i guess
for leadership change in russia
i don't think actually said he was
isolated but i talked about the people
around him um
it is impossible for me to judge
what vladimir putin is thinking
that's up to him to explain
okay i'm sorry we're going to have to go
on zoom uh
what's happening on the ground russia is
intensifying its attacks
for you i cannot announce
many things as of our allies
and we will continue to do
which will be announced in the coming
days
it's important for us to remember
that we have already
provided both lethal and non-lethal
assistance
and all options around the table at the
moment
we are continuing to think about what
else we can do to assist the people of
ukraine
are you surprised that mr putin is
intensifying and escalating his attacks
uh
and we have to respond
to work
we
see happening
on the ground
and we need to work
closely and coordinate our efforts
closely with partners and allies that is
what we are doing with the g7 allies and
the democratic world
we also need to say that we are
coordinating our efforts with ukraine
ukraine has very interesting and
creative ideas
ukrainians and listening to them for
upcoming measures
thank you we have time for the last
questions
toronto star
hey thank you very much uh can you hear
me okay
yes we can awesome
uh awesome um
just following up on mac's question
about uh abramovich
and the oligarchs that canada has not
sanctioned i'm
just uh hoping for some clarity on
you're promising additional measures
have we basically gone as far as sort of
international consensus is allowing us
to go or why haven't we gone further in
terms of uh
uh more
individuals in the in the putin circle
being sanctioned
i don't think it's really fair to
uh my colleagues around the world to
talk about the conversations we have
behind closed doors
i suspect that might make them less
enthusiastic about collaborating with
canada and listening to canada's great
new ideas
um
i think it's
yeah maybe i'll i'll leave it there and
i will just underscore
we are very aware of
the russian interests in canada these of
course are much less significant than
russian interests in
most of our partner
countries
but we're looking at those closely
and
you know as i've said
we will have additional economic
measures that will be taken in the days
to come
just as a follow-up to that um
you know there's an example of this
company that that's been in the news a
little bit talking about these sanctions
everest um the steel manufacturers got
operations in alberta and saskatchewan
um and it's been a major provider i
think the majority of the pipeline steal
for the trans mountain expansion has
actually come from this
this provider this company abramovic for
example is a majority or a major
stakeholder two other uh
you know uh named oligarchs are on the
board of management
um are we uh
worried and sanctioning or are are we
trying to not sanction companies that if
we sanction them there would be economic
pain in canada
um how are we approaching that in terms
of companies that have a significant
economic presence in canada that may be
tied to oligarchs in putin's circles
um so
when it comes to sanctions let me just
underscore
that we know
that
we are the most effective when we act
together and i think that one of the
reasons that
these sanctions
have been much tougher than russia
expected and have had a much tougher
impact than anyone expected before this
war began
is that we've managed to have
unprecedented unity among the
democracies
if you take for example the sanctions on
the reserves of the central bank of
russia
it really required
strong collective action for that to
work and have an impact so i want to
emphasize uh the practical value of
acting together with our allies
when it comes to yevraz let me say a
couple of things
um
the steel that was provided by yevraz
for the tmx pipeline
was uh fully delivered by the second
quarter of 2020
when sanctions were not in place and the
war had not yet begun
um
i have said and i really want to
emphasize everything is on the table and
we are looking carefully at the holdings
of oligarchs in canada
something i learned during our
trade wars with the united states
uh
and it feels almost quaint to recall a
time when that was our concern
um but something that i learned
something that canada learned is
tariffs and retaliation and sanctions
are the most effective when you can
devise policies that have the maximum
impact
on the counterparty whose attention you
are seeking to get and do the minimal
damage to yourself
and certainly the western world has
thought about that
in putting together the sanctions
package against russia
but i think we all also
really have understood
that
at the end of the day
if
we are truly determined to stand with
ukraine
if the stakes in this fight are as high
as i believe them to be
we have to be honest with ourselves i
have to be honest with canadians
that there could be some collateral
damage in canada
and that's something that the g7 finance
ministers discussed very early this
morning
we spoke candidly with one another and
we said
in order to be really effective in order
to really have an impact
we are going to have to be prepared
for there to be
some adverse consequences for our own
economies
of course that is much much much more
true for our european partners than it
is for us
but it's the reality and
i think
that that's something you know canadians
are smart uh i think canadians
understand that
i really do believe that canadians
understand the stakes of this fight
and
i believe that canadians understand that
we need to be prepared to do things
that are hard
to do things that are costly
to avoid something which would be
much more damaging to canada
which is
a successful occupation by vladimir
putin of ukraine with all of the
consequences that that would have
have a great day
you